[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir d'urban après les
inondations les dégâts sont
considérables et les pertes humaines
très lourdes au moins 445 personnes ont
péri et le bilan pourrait s'alourdir
davantage le président cyril ramaphosa a
déclaré l'état de catastrophe nationale
notre envoyé spécial caroline du mais
s'est rendu sur place témoignage dans un
instant le tri ce week-end de pâques
dans l'est de la république démocratique
du congo les populations qui avaient fui
les combats entre l'armée et le m23 sont
rentrées chez elles elles certaines ont
pu assister à la messe les détails dans
ce journal et puis à la fin de cette
édition nous irons au togo souvenez-vous
le groupe bolloré avait annoncé il y a
quelques semaines la rétrocession de
toutes ses activités de transport et de
logistique dans une quarantaine de ports
africains un amateur italo au sua
l'armateur italo-suisse au togo le
groupe y était très bien implanté une
présence qui a suscité beaucoup de
polémiques reportage à suivre
scène de désolation à à durban en
afrique du sud une semaine après le
début des inondations les autorités ont
déployé en renfort dix mille soldats
pour aider à déblayer et à rechercher
les victimes le bilan fait état de 445
mort 80% du réseau d'eau potable est
hors service les habitants qui ont
encore un toit sont également privés
d'électricité
notre correspondante dans la dans le
pays s'est rendu sur place avec elle est
la plupart dont s'entretenir avec les
habitants l'état des lieux et les
témoignages tout de suite avec ce
reportage de caroline dumas stéphane
carstens
il pleut toujours dans la banlieue de
durban les sauveteurs sont là depuis
près d'une semaine et ils fouillaient
encore les décombres
les conditions sont difficiles le
terrain est glissant
les autorités ont demandé aux
populations d'évacuer ces zones
dangereuses
ici à inanda il n'y a plus aucune chance
de retrouver des survivants
les chiens sont là pour repérer les
corps enterrés dans la boue avec tigana
mir kenneth khumalo et le voisin de la
famille maeght wazi qui s'est retrouvé
enseveli
les maisons qui étaient là a été emporté
par les épingles a glissé on la mère a
survécu mais le père est mort il y avait
deux enfants l'instant on ne sait pas où
ils
les deux enfants n'ont jamais été
retrouvés ils ont peut-être été enterrés
vivants les résidents explique que la
plupart de leurs maisons n'ont pas de
fondations ou n'est sorti on a vu que
les murs bougent et qui glissait vers le
bas et l'humeur de la première maison a
poussé le mur de la deuxième la première
a glissé puis la deuxième aussi des
ponts se sont effondrés des routes ont
été éventrés il y avait eu ici en une
seule journée l'équivalent de neuf mois
de pluie cet ingénieur nous explique que
la force des eaux a même fait bouger des
containers
les containers ont été soulevées et ils
ont flotté sur l'autoroute pendant sept
ou huit kilomètres jusqu'à complètement
détruire le pont
tout le pays est venu au secours de la
province sinistrée
dix mille soldats vont être déployés les
autorités admettent qu'elles sont
totalement débordés
nous remercions les provinces qui nous
ont aidés on apprécie vraiment leur
soutien humanitaire minutes
personne n'a encore estimé le coût de
cette catastrophe mais la seule
réhabilitation des routes coûte aurait
au pays plus de 200 millions d'euros
on vous parle à présent de la lutte
contre le terrorisme une force militaire
conjointe du nigeria du niger et du
cameroun a déclaré dimanche avoir tué au
cours des dernières semaines plus de 100
insurgés islamistes dont dix commandants
une annonce qui intervient alors que la
tension sécuritaire est très forte aux
frontières du sud et ouest du niger la
correspondance et niamey d'aral gérard
ses succès militaire est également à
mettre au crédit du gouvernement
nigérien qui il y a quelques semaines
déjà affirmé sa volonté de renforcer la
coopération militaire avec le nigeria
cette opération aurait duré plusieurs
semaines récemment dans la région du lac
tchad 18 soldats de la force conjointe
entre le niger le nigeria et le cameroun
aurait ont été blessés par des engins
explosifs improvisés les troupes qui
traquait les positions de boko haram
mais aussi de l'état islamique en
afrique de l'ouest ont mené une double
offensive au sol et dans les airs mais
pour plusieurs experts ces succès ne
sont durables qu'à partir du moment où
ils les implique par la suite un
renforcement des moyens
réalité dans la zone
de la région des différends notamment
dans la zone du bassin du lac tchad tel
le problème c'est que quand on essaie
d'analyser la présence de forces
nationales mixtes c'est que et les
groupes terroristes profitent du retrait
du retrait de ces forces là du manque de
permanence de ces forces là dans les
zones pour essayer de se réinstaller et
à chaque fois quand la menace militaire
elle est accru la menace militaire est
forte il essaye de se retirer pour aller
mieux s'organiser la frontière entre le
niger et le nigeria reste aujourd'hui
l'une des zones les plus dangereuses du
continent africain d'après le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés
c'est plus de 235 mille personnes
déplacées de force qui vivent dans la
région nigérienne de diffa la région
voisine du nord du nigeria
en guinée le retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel est désormais soumis au
recensement général de la population un
document publié vendredi par les
autorités détailler les 10 étapes clés
qui doivent mener au retour des civils
au pouvoir un plan de transition qui
divise déjà non pas de par son contenu
mais plus à cause de l'absence d'une
date butoir pour l'exécution de ce plan
les détails avec notre correspondant à
conakry mali t quitter dans ce document
de 56 pages transmis aux partis
politiques le retour des civils au
pouvoir doit être précédé de dix étapes
clés notamment le recensement général et
administratif de la population
l'établissement d'un fichier électoral
l'élaboration et l'adoption d'une
nouvelle constitution
mais le document ne précise aucun
calendrier pour l'exécution des chacune
de ces étapes pour l'alliance nationale
pour l'alternance démocratique une
coalition dirigé par cellou dalein
diallo les militaires au pouvoir joue la
montre c'est seulement après c'est moi
qui nous ressort le ccc c'est bizarre ça
veut dire vraiment que le nrb
et
l'intention n'est ce pas de s'accrocher
au pouvoir et le recensement général de
la population est important est la mise
en place d'un fichier d'état civil a été
important mais et le temps que tout cela
s'apprend n'est ce pas ce n'est pas la
mission en un gouvernement de transition
la copa d' une autre coalition politique
après l'initiative elle estime qu'il
faut dès maintenant poser les bases
d'une élection transparente
c'est maintenant qu'il faut poser les
bases pour avoir un bon fichier
l'épreuve il faut le sens et il faut
savoir ce qui peut voter ceux qui n'ont
pas le droit de voter donc c'est
important qu'ils aient ses actions pour
la voile un fichier électoral parfait
accepté vu tout le monde qui va nous
permettre d'avoir des élections libres
transparentes
la cedeao menace toujours d'imposer à la
guinée des sanctions économiques et
financières après le 25 avril si les
militaires au pouvoir ne précise pas
d'ici là un calendrier de restitution du
pouvoir aux civils
ces images de bouées antipollution
déployés par l'armée tunisienne autour
du pétrolier qui a coulé ce week-end des
plongeurs ont été dépêchés pour
inspecter la coque du navire sous l'eau
le pétrolier qui a fait naufrage avait
pardon près de gabès au large des côtes
tunisiennes étaient chargés de 750
tonnes de gazole pour le moment aucune
fuite n'a été détectée selon les
autorités
la colère de la société civile dans
l'est de la république démocratique du
congo deux soldats en état d'ivresse ont
tué 15 personnes dimanche cette mort en
ituri 8 dans le sud kivu beaucoup
s'inquiètent de la recrudescence des
tueries perpétrées par des militaires en
état d'ivresse ou sous un choc
émotionnel un phénomène de plus en plus
fréquents depuis que les provinces du
nord kivu et de l'ituri ont été a placé
sous état de siège un état de siège qui
n'a d'ailleurs pas empêché les massacres
ces dernières semaines les populations
fuient les combats entre l'armée et la
milice du m23 de nombreuses familles
sont rentrées chez elles elles ont pu se
réunir pour le week-end de pâques
certaines ont même pu assister à la
messe de pâques laurent berthet cher
[Musique]
quelques dizaines de fidèles se pressent
pour recevoir l'eucharistie
avant de rejoindre la chorale
ils sont venus assister à la seule messe
de pâques tenue dans la paroisse de
jomba au nord kivu une région minée par
l'insécurité et les violences
nissan et a largué la mèche s'est bien
déroulée mais il n'y avait pas beaucoup
de monde la plupart des gens sont wacan
dans le refuge même si certains
fin mars les rebelles du groupe m23
avaient attaqué et occupé plusieurs
villages dans l'est de la rdc avant de
se retrancher dans les collines les
combats ont poussé les populations à
fuir vers rutshuru chef lieu de la
province du même nom une ville ne
disposant d'aucune structure d'accueil
et qui a vite été dépassé par l'afflux
de réfugiés
suite à une récente accalmie certains
habitants ont commencé à rentrer dans
leurs villages même si les forces de
sécurité restent sur le qui vive parmi
eux la bedimo banzi qui avaient été
évacués par l'armée après avoir été pris
dans les combats
nous remercions notre curé nous pensions
qu'il était mort nous avions vers uchuu
et nous venons de rentrer nous notre
prêtre
si les fidèles ont pu se réunir pour le
week-end de pâques les célébrations ont
dû être écourtées la traditionnelle
veillée du samedi soir a notamment été
annulés à cause de l'insécurité qui
continue de régner au nord kivu
le groupe bolloré a annoncé il ya
quelques semaines la rétrocession de
toutes ses activités de transport et de
logistique dans une quarantaine de ports
africains à l'armateur italo-suisse msc
au togo bolloré africaine logistique
était implanté officiellement depuis
plus d'une dizaine d'années une présence
qui a suscité beaucoup de polémique dans
le pays la société civile les médias et
l'opposition ont toujours dénoncé la
collusion entre le pouvoir de lomé et
l'homme d'affaires reportage d'emmanuel
sodji le port de lomé au togo tout comme
celui de conakry en guinée font partie
des plus belles acquisitions du
milliardaire français vincent bolloré
mais elles sont aussi à la source de ses
démêlés judiciaires
l'année dernière devant le parquet
financier français l'industriel a
reconnu avoir obtenu la gestion du port
en échange du financement de la campagne
présidentielle en 2010 de faure
gnassingbé l'actuel chef de l'état
togolais le régime gnassingbé confisqué
le pouvoir d'état au togo depuis 54 ans
et ça c'est pas le fait de versant
bolloré en revanche avec leur puissance
financière les gens congrès semblerait
consolide la dictature en plaidant
coupable vincent bolloré et deux de ses
collaborateurs
espérer vite lors la faire moyennant une
amende l'entreprise a obtenu gain de
cause mais pas les individus ce qui
ouvre la voie à un procès en
correctionnelle
mais d'ores et déjà deux perdants de la
présidentielle togolaise de 2010 at bio
mais kodjo et brigitte adjamagbo johnson
se sont portées parties civiles de dadis
ce qui peut éventuellement se avoir subi
un préjudice donnant à cette corruption
le groupe bolloré n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions de leur côté
les autorités togolaises que nous avons
contactés n'ont pas fait suite non plus
à nos sollicitations
selon elle le dossier bolloré est une
affaire franco française les foyens
single a été personnellement impliqué et
eidur tu ne dis ça sur 1000 pages sans
résister par tous partout donc on est
concerné on peut pas dire que ça une
affaire franco française c'est pas
possible c'est pas vrai le célèbre
journaliste d'investigation ferdinand
ayité pointe du doigt lui des
arrangements entre le pouvoir et vincent
bolloré au détriment des intérêts du
pays
qu'à
l'extérieur et c'est ça qui est
véritablement révoltant de la part des
dirigeants de nos pays sadik on signe
des contrats avec des investisseurs au
détriment des peuples et un beau matin
on se dit bon bah écoutez j'ai plus
envie de rester dans votre poche je m'en
vais tout ce que j'ai ramassé combes
bénéfice est pour moi et qu'est ce que
vont la gagner à l'arrivée tout comme le
départ de vincent bolloré du port
togolais prévue l'année prochaine reste
entouré d'un flou pour l'instant
impossible d'avoir accès aux conditions
d'avant des actifs au togo au 3e
armateur au monde aime et c'est le seul
chiffre connu c'est la transaction
totale pour la quarantaine de ports
africains elle est de 5 7 milliards
d'euros
et on termine par ce visage celui de
l'athlète kényan evans chebet il s'est
imposé sur le marathon de boston en deux
heures six minutes et 51 secondes
décrochant ainsi sa première victoire
dans un marathon majeur et chez les
femmes c'est aussi une kényane qui a
remporté la course la championne
olympique en titre perez jet chirchir
elle s'est imposée en 2h21 et une
secondes juste devant l'éthiopienne à
babel yaiche à nez
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]
à
amoureux millau
on
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour je viens pour
faire ma dose de rappel il ya des rendez
vous à ne pas manquer pour continuer à
vous protéger penser dès maintenant à
votre dose de rappel
on est à maubeuge dans les hautes france
aminata yacine et nawfal ont fait le
déplacement depuis leur quartier avec
cette chaise pliante pour rencontrer la
france de 2022 nous on fait une petite
émission qui consiste à poser trois
petites questions aux gens c'est même
pas quelque chose qu'on fait pour pour
le plaisir des fois c'est un devoir les
quartiers à l'écouté des français c'est
cette semaine dans chaque quartier pas
de quartier à voir sur france 24 et
france 24 points comme
[Musique]